well you remember of course that viral
video of the woman on the plane who uh
saw The Reptilian demon and then
understandably got I got a little upset
and she got up and left and um
we never found out who that woman was or
what her name is
and the reason we didn't find out
is because and to this point
it's because we don't need to know
we really just don't need to know it
doesn't matter at all it's not relevant
who cares so I know after that happened
and I was I was uh
out of the loop when when the when the
this viral thing first blew up
but I know for weeks after that there
are a lot of people social media saying
who is this woman no one knows who she
is she's disappeared it's a great
mystery it's not a mystery she's just a
person and she's off living her life
somewhere now and she's not going out of
her way to identify herself to the
internet mob that's not nothing
mysterious about that but why do we need
to know who it is what difference does
it make
um it makes no difference at all it's
not relevant but that didn't stop the
media
and the media has now hunted this woman
down
and they have published her name her age
her occupation
the neighborhood where she lives and a
photo of her house
so here's the Daily Mail
uh the woman behind the shocking that
mother effort back there is not real
airplane meltdown has been unmasked as a
38 year old Dallas marketing executive
um I'm not even going to say the name it
doesn't matter because it's all over the
place anyway but still she became
erratic over an argument with the
relatives that uh okay she became a
radical over an argument with relatives
that she was traveling with she
reportedly told police the Dallas
resident had accused her relatives of
stealing her air pods
and that is supposedly what sparked all
this
after she claimed her relatives had
stolen her airpods she began to say that
their plan was not safe and would not
make it to its destination
official documents say that she was not
willing to leave the plane had to be
removed by American Airlines staff
following the Outburst Etc who cares
and then they go into a lot of details
about where she lives like specifically
her neighborhood her actual neighborhood
which lives
more into her work history her resume
you know and then and then as I said a
photograph of her house
is is published
who
and this is the kind of thing the media
can just do and there's no consequence
at all
you are it
you are directly trying to ruin This
Woman's life for no reason
and it's not even like this is one this
is something with a political motive
and that wouldn't be okay either but at
least when they do that you you
understand what their motive is that
okay they're political partisans they're
trying to destroy someone's life because
uh they're on the other side of an issue
but there's nothing political about this
we don't know anything about this
woman's politics
um she's a middle-aged white woman in
Dallas the chances that she is a
Democrat seem pretty high uh but who
knows doesn't matter
there's no political element at all it's
just a it was just kind of like a weird
story and it was a weird video that
people paid attention to and and cared
about way more than they should
now there's one thing that's really
important to me it's living a healthy
lifestyle something of a health nut I
think you pick up that Vibe for me don't
you and that's why I was so excited that
we could partner with balance of nature
fruits and Vegeta veggies uh and they're
a great way to make sure that you're
getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day through
balance of Nature's Advanced cold vacuum
process the vitamins minerals and
phytonutrients of the fruits and
vegetables are preserved so you can get
that vital nutrition in each capsule
balance of nature is a whole food
supplement with no additives no fillers
no extracts no synthetics synthetics no
pesticides no added sugar pure fruits
and veggies are the only things that
they put in their capsules battle nature
sent a bunch of their products down to
the studio for my team to try we all
love them when you're disciplined enough
to take care of your health you reap all
kinds of benefits your body will thank
you for a limited time this summer when
you become a preferred customer at
balance of nature they're throwing in a
free fruit and veggie travel set and
giving an additional 25 off your first
order go to bouncingature.com use promo
code Walsh for a free travel set and 25
off your first order as a preferred
customer that's balanceofnature.com
promo code Welsh
so what exactly so we don't have the
normal political explanation for this
that at least makes much some kind of
sense of it
that doesn't exist here so what is the
motive
if you're in the media and you're a
reporter
and you find yourself
publishing a story
unmasking This Woman's name and
everything else about her
and then even publishing a photograph of
her house
in your head what are you saying to
yourself to justify this
how you must be saying something you
must be telling yourself
this is newsworthy everyone needs to
know this woman's name and where she
lives and what her house looks like and
where specifically you can find her
everyone needs to know this uh because
what
that's what I want to know how do you
rationalize it to yourself
maybe I'm giving them too much credit in
the media by assuming that they feel the
need to rationalize it to themselves
the media's comprise largely of I mean
these are the reptilian monsters
themselves like they just act on
Instinct it's like it's just an Insight
they probably don't even think about it
oh yeah this is a woman that was in a
viral video and um
yeah we should just publish everything
about her embarrass her publicly and try
to ruin her life because that's what we
do why not
I imagine that's that's as much analysis
as they've given the situation
is really uh really contemptible hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code walls
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there